yeah I'm I'm a bit rushed I've only got
a few billions of billions of atos
seconds to talk to you a safety officer
Peter Milligan shouted across oh out to
Second physics for the Nobel Prize this
year and what what went through your
head um well I remembered a lab that I
visited at the NRC in Ottawa probably
about 20 years ago lab called of um a
person called Paul Coram and um at the
time I was working on Quantum dots at
the NRC and there was a buzz around Paul
coram's lab and um I knew that this was
serious work going on and so when I um
heard the Nobel Prize gone to a second
physics I thought Paul corham it's got
to be Paul corham um but it wasn't um so
it went to anier Frank Krauss and uh
Pierre austino it's for probably the
shortest pulse of of light that we can
get and in in some ways it's like the
ultimate shutter speed on a camera so
when we take pictures of things that are
moving rapidly you need to have a fast
shutter speed if you've ever gone out
and tried to take a picture of a
hummingbird right the hummingbird's
wings beat at 80 per per second or
something so if you were to set your
shutter speed at say a second so it
would have fluted 80 times by then you
just see a blurred image so you've got
to set your shutter speed maybe a
thousandth of a second to make sure you
can isolate this and what these people
have done is they've developed the
technology and built the experiments
which allow you to actually probe the
movement of electrons in an atom so it
maybe it's worthwhile seeing why that
needs to be an what's called an atoc
second an atoc second is a billionth of
a billionth of a second so that's 10
the- 18 seconds so there are 10 to the
18 atoc seconds in a second there are
more ATO seconds in a in a second than
there are seconds in the ede of the
universe that's okay okay I saw your
head Go whoo and the universe is 13.8
billion years old so that is about 10 to
the 17 seconds but there's 10 to the 18
ATO seconds in a second so they're
making a pulse of light that lasts that
long it lasts about I think the current
rate is is about 200 atoc second no it's
down sorry it's down to a few dozens
atoc seconds 20 at seconds or so yeah
that's what a current pulse of light can
be but they're not shining that light on
to an electron and seeing it like the
wings of a hummingbird well they are
able to look at the it's not an
individual electron I I believe it's
they they can't be looking at an a an
object and saying the core of that
object is the electron because we've got
an uncertainty principle right which
tells us the the closer you get to pin
down the position of an electron the
less you know about its velocity for
example so what they're looking at is is
the wave the the wave function which you
associate with the El where it's
maximized and they can look at that at
different moments and in 20 atoc seconds
the electron can have gone from one side
of an atom to another side of an atom as
it orbits right electrons orbit atoms
and these can probe that so they can
actually sort of see where it's
maximized here and then 20 atos seconds
later see where it's over here so when
we think of an atom we think of
something that's about an angstrom right
10- 10 m and we're using light to probe
it and light is moving at a speed of 10
to 8 m a second so every second a photon
of light goes 100 million M so in 10- 18
seconds it goes one angstrom you can go
from that to that so 10 the- 18 for
light corresponds to an angstrom so it's
the typical time scale for an electron
to go around so that is the motivation
for why ATO ATO seconds is is a scale to
go for but people didn't think it was
possible because we've had had lasers
for a long time and these are laser
pulses that are used and lasers it was
thought were the maximum time scale that
you could get um for a pulse was 10
Theus 15 seconds that's called a fto
second that's that corresponds to the
frequency of of light that that you
produce with with lasers you know
visible light or even if you go into the
ultravalet you can't go much above a
ftoc but that's still a thousand times
bigger than an atoc second so the
electron would have gone whizzing round
a thousand times it's like our wings on
the huming like our wings on the
hummingbird so it was regarded and up
until the 1980s that that this was that
was going to be the best you could
achieve and then um a group of people
including our Nobel Prize winners they
started asking is that can we do better
and they made use of the of of the
following that that it's possible to add
waves of light together and these waves
can have different wavelengths and they
can have different amplitudes and you
can add them together so that they will
individually they won't they'll be too
big or they'll be too long but added
together they can actually form a
profile of the right size and lasts the
right length of time so in principle
there was this process which is just
adding waves together we do it in
mathematics all the time it's called
furier series we add waves together to
create new waves of different
frequencies and different amplitudes the
big question was how are you going to do
it in a physical context Anu I think
she's called she realized that there was
a potential way to do it and what she
did was she fired infrared light into a
gas of in fact it was neon now now let's
just go into the atom of the gas for a
moment we've got an atom we've got an
electron sitting there happily it's it's
not been it's a rare gas it's very
relaxed not doing much it's it's trapped
by the electric field of the rest of the
atom pulling it in and then in Comes
This wave and it hits the atom it
excites the electron and a photon of
light right has a electric field and a
magnetic field it's and it's propagating
along the electric field of this light
hits the electron if it's got enough
intensity to it the electron tunnels out
of the atom and now it's free okay so
the electron disappears off and you
think well okay it's going to go and
leave me with an ion behind but what
actually happens is the electric field
of this photon's changing all the time
it's oscillating backwards and forwards
up and down its direction is changing an
electric field is a force so as it
passed the atom initially it's let's say
it's pointing in that direction it's
forcing the electron in that direction
as it goes by it switches Direction so
the down bit of the wave comes back past
the electron and it forces it back and
so from being in a rear Zoom where it
pushes the electron off it changes sign
and pulls it back and the electron goes
up and comes back down towards the atom
but now it's got this energy it's gained
this energy CU it's the photon of light
has passed it onto it it it can't get
into the atom with all this energy it's
got to release that energy so this
kinetic energy of the electron gets
released as an ultra high frequency beam
of light ultraviolet beam of light goes
shooting off the electron gets
reabsorbed this is happening all around
this gas right this gas is full of atoms
each of these atoms I mean I don't know
if it's every one of them is getting
excited the electrons are shooting off
different distances coming back emitting
this light so now all of a sudden I've
got these pulses of Light which are
emerging all with different frequencies
but a key ingredient is that each of
these frequencies is related to the
frequency of the original light coming
in because they've had a certain amount
of energy transferred so there's a very
important relationship between them and
what she showed was first of all that
the intensity of all these These are
called overtones by the way these these
extra high frequency light that's coming
out they're called overtones that the
intensity of all these overtones was
very similar so that they all were
contributing the same amount typically
to what would was going to then happen
okay now we come to school physics what
happens when you have two waves that
overlap one another do you remember
Crest plus Crest big Crest trough plus
Crest zero you've now got all these
waves superimposing on one another and
every now and again you'd get crests
building so you got a big peak all
around it then it drops down can you see
what I'm drawing I'm drawing first pulse
and then it happens here crests drops
down second pulse third pulse so out of
this she generated these
pulses each of these pulses is about a
few atos seconds now as far as I know
initially she didn't have a way of
determining the actual time scale of
this maybe she did I I don't know but
she had shown how it was possible for
this to happen to form these short
pulsed objects out of long pulsed
initial
waves and she'd shown that the that the
intensity of the of these overtones
which make up these pulses was such that
you could be guaranteed that you'd have
these strong signals it seems like a
really roundabout messy way to be doing
it and I think this is why they've got
the prize right it is such a difficult
thing to do I think that's been the the
the the technology that they've had to
introduce
is probably why they they they've got it
because it's gone to three
experimentalists the wolf Prize last
year which is another huge Prize in
physics went to two of these people and
a theorist theorist hasn't got it this
time around so two of the Nobel Prize
winners he shared the the the um wolf
prize and that's generally thought to be
a kind of precursor of the Nobel quite a
few people have won the the wolf prize
one year and the Nobel next year as
happened this year um but in this case
Paul corham didn't share in the Nobel he
was um replaced by um Pierre austino is
anyone talking about why or have you had
have you seen any any rumors on the web
or it's just a mystery to you not really
um I I Googled it um and um in fact
Frank Krauss himself said it was a shame
that more than three people can't share
Noel priz because what Paul cam had done
was absolutely fundamental and
underpinned the work that led to the
Nobel um so I think probably the Nobel
committee focused on experimental work
whereas what Paul corham did was a lot
of really interesting work on the thing
called the um recollision electron model
where a laser can pull an electron away
from an atom that electron then moves
back very quickly towards the atom and
Emit and can emit photons in the extreme
ultraviolet bit of the spectrum as you
need for these really short pulses but
it was theory that that he did initially
then course he did experiments as well
how are they used as a tool right so the
next so that I think that part of the
prize is where lili's work came in
and then you've got the other twos who
came in with their their work was
actually to manipulate this so 2001
agustini realized that there was a way
in which he could use um like once again
use this laser beam this infrared laser
beam he split it in one of the channels
it he did this thing with the atoms
where it where it would go through neon
atoms and then form these pulses they
call them a pulse train so you can
imagine the the the the size of the
pulse so you've got the pulse then
dropping down so that's one carriage and
then another pulse so it's that's you
have this pulse train and then what he
did was he split this initial beam in it
came the original infrared radiation
photons it splits the beam carries on
and then this split goes through the
neon creates my overtones and then they
recombine them and then the mathematics
for that recombining allows them to
determine the size of the pulse that has
been generated so for the first time I
think think they were able to say that
the length time scale of that atosc
pulse and it was 250 each of these
trains had a 250 ATO second pulse
length and the third person that has got
the prize Krauss I think he's called he
developed a technique to isolate out
single pulses so he could create single
pulses he found the length of his single
pulse was 650 atos seconds he did
something really interesting it harks
back to the Nobel Prize of Albert
Einstein what did Albert Einstein win
the Nobel Prize F not for relativity he
won it for the photoelectric effect a
calculation he did in 2 in 1905 not 2005
1905 a photon of light comes into a
material hits the material if it's got
high enough energy it excites the an
electron which gets emitted and you can
predict the speed with which it comes
out as being the difference between the
the energy of the light coming in and
The Binding energy keeping the electron
there and then that was that experiment
was confirmed and he got the Nobel Prize
in
1921 there was no way of knowing whether
this is an instantaneous effect or if
there is there a time delay but Krauss
did this experiment with these pulses he
followed a photon coming in so it hit
the atom 100 EV pulse I think coming in
it excited the electron and and the
electrons came from two different
orbitals you know atoms have orbitals
right different energy levels one came
out from a 2s orbital the higher one and
one from the 2p which is lower down the
2p1 came out he said 21 atoc seconds
later than the
2s1 okay so these first of all measure
the time difference but this difference
could be calculated using quantum
chemistry and and basically Atomic
physics the theoretical values were
different from his values by a fact of
two and
ler she came onto the scene and redid
this experiment in her own way and she
got the same result as the theoreticians
so there was something called what did
they call it shaking in Cruiser's
experiment that she'd managed to avoid
apparently and so their result matched
the theoretical results of of quantum
mechanics so you've got this these
experiments
and what they seem to be doing I think
the Nobel Prize people have been quite
quick in given it and that it's still
early days in the development of the
technology in that the kind of physics
that it's been applied to is kind of
really academic if you like it's trying
to understand charge distributions
around an atom charge swapping when when
one atom will swap charges within and
ions will form it's it's sort of homing
in on using this very fine scale of time
to be able to probe the motion of
electrons that's the key thing they're
doing here they can probe the motion of
electrons you're telling me these pulses
of light can be used
to geolocate the position of the
electron yeah not ex I mean it depends
what we mean there by electron and GE
okay it cannot pin down a point and say
the electron is there it can't it can't
because if it could if you could do that
then what would happen from Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle is then you'd have
no idea about the speed of that electric
that's okay if I don't want to know that
if I just want to know where it is and I
don't care what speed it's going at yeah
but I don't think that's the case here I
think they do want to know have
information on both its position and its
and its speed I think but it's a really
good and important question I think what
they're looking at is the way form you
associate do you remember in quantum
mechanics you have particle and wave
Duality you can describe something
either as a particle or you can describe
it as a wave and I think these
descriptions are wavelike descriptions
so what you're looking for is the peak
amplitude of the wave because that tells
you where the electron is most likely to
be it feels like there's this sort of
growing body of worldclass scientists
who've been denied the Nobel Prize
because of the rules yeah no it it does
seem to be I mean science is teamwork
now everything is done in teams and
typically those teams have got a lot
more than three people in there so
having to condense a team into three
people that that actually win the award
um from the whole Global team of people
actually that develop a field is pretty
tough and in this case it seems to be to
be very tough uh to me what do you think
change the rules then I would yeah to
make it fair and to make sure that
controversy doesn't just dominate the
award every year and the science takes
Center Stage is the Nobel Prize still
important absolutely absolutely yeah I
mean it really shines a spotlight on a
field it shines a spotlight on what
science can do um not just the
fundamental physics which often attracts
young people into science um so but also
what can be done with that
science well first of all thank you for
having me in your lab what what do you
do here there's all this impressive
equipment kit Machinery what what kind
of physicist do you what do you do yeah
we like working with lasers because
they're really cool and allow us to do a
lot of um investigation of matter with
particular application in medicine so
what we want to do is to use light to
probe matter and to understand it and it
provides Us tool that we don't really
have to touch or to interfere with the
sample we just send light in and we
record the light that comes back and
that carries us the information we need
to understand what's happening in our
sample Professor why does the light have
to be a a short pulse why couldn't you
just put a constant source of light on
the thing you're studying well it all
depends on what the process you try to
understand so for example in this
experiment here we are trying to
discriminate between the light that
interacts with matter in the way that we
are interested which is a spontaneous
effect but at the same time light can
induce other processes which take for
example the absorption of electrons and
then reemission of light but that takes
time but that time it's very very short
but however in order to discriminate
between the two we have to use very
short uh laser pounces the Nobel Prize
this week in physics seems to have been
related to the sort of work you do tell
me was it closely related tell me about
that I think it's exciting work isn't it
it's just yeah I mean just want to put
into context for the phenomenon that we
want to observe here we use what's
called
PICC um uh laser pulses now the Noble
Prize is about because that is what is
relevant for this particular experiment
for the Nobel Prize work so the the the
the pulses of light they were used there
the were at a second to put it into
context this means it's like comparing
in one second compared to two weeks it
will take in our experiment so it's a
completely different time scale does
that mean they do you need much
different Machinery to achieve an at
second compared to your PCO second well
you can imagine this is very novel work
and it is even actually measuring the
pulses this type of course it's very
complex it's very much the fundamental
physics here we are applying for
measurements on real biological samples
to try to understand biological events
that happen in yeah if you flashed a
light in my eye for a Pico second would
I ever see it happen or is it too quick
for me to know it happened I think that
F will be too quick you may obviously
because of the effects depending on the
power it may damage your eye pretty
certainly whether your brain will
recognize I don't know I think you have
when a Nobel Prize is given in your
field what does it mean for you it's
just amazing it's exciting the the way
in which I start the the first lecture
of my modules which are typically in in
Optics or in lasers or in advanced super
resolution imaging I started with the
Nobel prizes in this field I think we're
lucky so coming back from the 64 with
the invention of with the Nobel Prize
awarded for the laser at the time we're
saying it's a technology looking for
applications now come 60 years and
lasers are everywhere and Nobel priz is
coming over very very often you telling
me your pico second laser here has
applications has medical applications um
what does an atosc laser have
applications for I think at the moment
what we have to think is the
extraordinary science that we can do
with it so we have to think that the
electron takes about few hundreds at a
second to go around the the nucleus of
hydrogen so what we can do is actually
looking a very fundamental science
related to the you know Rel to the
electrons to the way in which atoms
vibrate chemical reactions that happen
at those sort of time scales this is
just amazing I guess this is so exciting
that coming later I think applications
perhaps will be much later than that
Professor you told me the 1964 Nobel
Prize for lasers forms part of your
lectures here in Nottingham is the 2023
Nobel Prize going to be part of your
lectures too oh absolutely is going to
be there definitely on the slide and
potentially the fourth year modules
we're teaching absolutely we always like
to expose the students and to excite
with this so this is just great for for
my area of physics can you show me me
where is your laser here I can't where's
the heart of your experiment here or
your well one problem working with
lasers the beams have to be to fully
enclosed just for the safety so you can
see the laser will be in this part here
and it's fully connected and covered by
tubes to be delivered on the microscope
so that will be a a tiny laser just that
box yep do you buy your lasers off the
shelf or do you have to make them we buy
off the shelves because we as I
mentioned my my work is very much in
understanding biophysical processes and
potentially developing medical devices
using lasers so the first thing what you
want to do is to have reliable lasers uh
that you can actually use thanks for
watching this video as you may know
we've been making films like this about
the Nobel Prize in physics for quite a
few years now there's a whole playlist
of them which I'll link to in the video
description also in the video
description there'll be a link to the
University of Nottingham's physics and
astronomy Department you can find find
out more about what they're up to and
also opportunities to study at Notting
them yourself as I said all those links
are down below